[Music]
Five Nights at Freddy's 2 is officially
in the works the Mandalorian is coming
to the big screen and a new Star Trek
movie is also in the pipeline all this
and much more to be covered in this
week's Koch Che news stay
tuned it has now been confirmed that
Caitlyn dver will play Ellie's
antagonist Abby in the second season of
The Last of Us there has been long
speculation about dver being cast in The
Last of Us among fans the books smart
Act was regarded as the big favorite of
the role of Ellie but it is well known
that the part went to Bella Ramsey who
also gave an impressive performance
there is still reason to be happy
however as naughty dog announced via ex
dver has now been cast for the role of
Abby Abby is a central character from
the 2020 sequel The Last of Us Part Two
and acts as Ellie's opponent the
character caused quite a stir due to her
masculine appearance as some fans
accused Naughty Dog of wanting to
forcibly change the traditional image of
a woman depending on how Abby is
implemented to the series dver could
also be faced with these criticisms
however her Casting was approved by a
large part of the Gaming Community we
are particularly excited to see how the
rather slender dver will shape up for
the role she was last featured in the
horror flick no one will save you other
familiar faces are also joining the cast
Isabella mered will play Ellie's friend
Dena mered is also known from Dora in
the Golden City and will soon be seen in
the Spider-Man spin-off Madam web beef
actor young Mao has also joined the cast
for the second season he will be playing
the role of Jesse one of Ellie's friends
filming on season 2 of The Last of Us is
set to begin this year meaning that a
release in early 2025 seems feasible
according to Craig Mason and Neil
Duckman season 2 will be adapting part
two of the game but not the entire
storyline apparently they still want to
keep sufficient material on hand for a
potential third
season it's finally official the
Mandalorian is getting its very own
movie adventure with man and grou also
there's news about the Disney plus
series Ahsoka the Mandalorian is still
one of the most popular series in the
Star Wars universe and as a regular hit
among viewers the series currently
comprises three seasons and a
continuation has been as good as certain
the only question that has been the
subject of much speculation recently is
in what form this will happen as Lucas
film has now officially announced we can
indeed expect a the Mandalorian movie it
has the working title the Mandalorian
grou and is expected to go into
production this year rumors about a film
adaptation has been circulating on the
internet over the past few months and
now everything appears to be a done deal
John favro who was already in charge of
the series alongside Dave filon is set
to direct the film Clone Wars Legend
filon is also involved as a producer by
the way he is currently also busy with
his own Star Wars film according to
initial information it will be a kind of
Avengers movie in which a variety of
characters from the Mando verse will be
brought together as wonderful as the
announcement of the Mando film may be
the legitimate question now arises as to
what will become of the planned fourth
season after all it was already firmly
planned and was also due to start
filming this year there have been
constant discussions about whether a
possible movie would simply replace
season 4 and even now the fate of a
fourth season is disputed meanwhile Star
Wars episode 10 has been postponed for
the time being the new adventure about
Ray was actually supposed to kick off
the return of Star Wars in cinemas but
mando could now preempt this in the
course of the announcement of the
Mandalorian film it was likewise
announced that Ahsoka would be getting
another season we can also look forward
to the second season of Andor and the
new series Skeleton Crew and the acolyte
so there's a lot going on in the galaxy
far far away and we can hardly wait
until we get to see the next
projects another night at Freddy
Fazbear's pizzeria awaits us after the
success of the video game adaptation
Five Nights at Freddy's which grossed
almost $140 million at the box office in
the United States alone a sequel is now
set to follow according to lead actor
Josh Hutcherson the sequel is already in
the works worldwide the adaptation of
the popular horror game series even
managed to generate revenues of almost
$290 million so it's no wonder that
rumors about Five Nights at Freddy's 2
quickly spread in an interview with
variety lead actor Josh Hutcherson has
now revealed that work on the sequel is
already well underway as soon as the
script is finalized filming could begin
immediately Hutcherson hopes that part
two will also satisfy fans and can
hardly wait to finally get back on set
what's more the actor shared that his
The Hunger Games co-star Jennifer
Lawrence had congratulated him on the
success of Five Nights at Freddy's both
LED the US charts at the time Hutcherson
with the horror film in theaters and
Lawrence with her comedy no hard
feelings on Netflix it is not yet known
what Five Nights at Freddy's 2 will be
about however the director of part one
Emma Tammy has stated in past interviews
that the stories of the individual games
could very well be used as inspiration
there is of course plenty of potential
for further adaptations since the
franchise comprises 13 games and
numerous
books fans of suspenseful zombie movies
have reason to Rejoice Danny Bole and
Alex Garland the creative minds behind
the horror hit 28 Days Later are now
planning a further sequel to the 2002
zombie Thriller with 28 years later
according to the Hollywood reporter 28
years later will not only be the next
film in the series after 28 Weeks Later
in which Bole and Garland were solely
involved as producers the new work is
set to be the start of an entire Trilogy
Bole is directing the first movie while
Garland will write the screenplays for
all three parts each with a budget of
around $75 million over the years Bole
and Garland have repeatedly talked about
possible sequels but have now decided on
the concept of 28 years later 28 Days
Later was hugely successful over 20
years ago revitalizing the zombie genre
and providing lead actor Killian Murphy
with the final breakthrough in his
career which most recently reached a new
Peak with opener it's not yet clear when
where and how 28 years later will be
released at the moment Bole and Garland
are presenting the project to various
Studios and streaming
providers space infinite waiting well
Star Trek 4 is still under development
but the project doesn't seem to be
making any real progress
however that doesn't stop distributor
Paramount from already starting work on
the next Star Trek film The Studio has
hired director Toby Haynes who last took
on this task in the highly acclaimed
Star Wars series Andor as deadline
reports according to insiders it will be
an origin story set decades before the
original 2009 reboot the screenplay is
being written by Seth Graham Smith who
also penned the script for the upcoming
Beetlejuice 2 this Star Trek film is
also being produced by JJ Abrams company
Bad Robot although it has been 8 years
since the last movie Star Trek beyond
the franchise is being constantly
expanded be it with current series such
as strange new worlds and Discovery or
the film Project section 31 the fourth
part of the reboot Saga or the work that
has just been announced Star Trek fans
can therefore look forward to plenty
more in the coming
years there's a new addition to the cast
of guod Del Toro Frankenstein Jacob El
Lordi will replace Andrew Garfield in
the role of the famous movie monster
Mary Shell's novel Frankenstein is
considered one of the great Classics of
the horror genre and has been adapted
for the cinema many times the best known
version is probably James Wales
production from the 1930s now another
movie adaptation is to follow for which
monster expert guo Del Toro will be
responsible for in collaboration with
Netflix Frankenstein comes with a
remarkable cast Oscar Isaac will take on
the role of Victor Frankenstein moreover
Mia goth Christopher Boltz all quiet on
the Western Front star Felix camer Lis
mikkelson and David Bradley have all
been confirmed for the project the role
of Frankenstein's monster was originally
supposed to be played by Andrew Garfield
but as deadline reports this part will
now be played by Euphoria star Jacob El
lordy El Lordi is regarded as one of the
most sought-after young actors in
Hollywood and can currently be seen in
the satire hit salt as well as in the
biopic Priscilla so far it remains
uncertain as to when we can expect the
movie however if production starts soon
a release in 2025 could seem
realistic and that's it for this week's
most important updates as always you can
check out further news on kino.com and
if you're in the mood to watch another
video have a look at our newest alien
Romulus movie preview thanks for
watching and see you next week for more
Hollywood
news
[Music]